so tonight i'm announcing additional  steps to strengthen our economic  recovery  we'll be expanding covet 19 economic  injury disaster loan programs  that's a program that's going to allow  small businesses  to borrow up to 2 million dollars from  the current five hundred thousand  to keep going if covet 19 impacts on  their sales  these low-interest long-term loans  require no repayment for two years  and be can use to hire and retain  workers  purchase inventory  or even pay down higher cost debt racked  up since the pandemic began  i'll also be taking additional steps to  help small businesses stay afloat during  the pandemic